bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le site du
figaro bienvenue sur figaro live c'est
figaro live débat opinions ses points de
vue avec ce soir barbara lefebvre
professeur écrivain contributrice de la
nouvelle revue front populaire fondée
par michel onfray et stéphane simon et
auteur de c'est ça la france et de
l'indispensable génération j'ai le droit
bonsoir barbara ans à sylvie bommel est
avec nous également grand reporter et
viau graff on signale pénélope et on
signale également il venait d'avoir 17
ans allusion à emmanuel macron et sa
rencontre avec brigitte macron alors
sylvie j'ai appris une chose aujourd'hui
c'est que vous n'aimez pas visiblement
prendre après minuit des bières avec les
amis d'edouard balladur et vous avez
assouvi récemment un vieux rêve quand on
vous lit c'est pas vous faire injure
c'est pas vous manquer de respect c'est
pas manqué de tact mais je peux me
demande si ceux ci quand même c'était
pas un fantasme
vous avez été pour la première fois de
votre vie à ses soeurs de bureaux de
vote
c'était un jour particulier c'était le
jour du premier tour des élections
municipales vous raconter ça c'est
absolument mais formidable à lire comme
toujours d'ailleurs c'est la première
fois quand je vous avais lu je m'étais
dit il faut que vous soyez sur le
plateau et bien j'en ai la confirmation
en venant de dire donc votre dernier
récit à retrouver dans vanity fair on
retrouve avec plaisir un homme qu'on a
toujours plaisir à lire et à entendre
c'est christian makarian bonsoir
christian bonsoir à toutes et d'un bon
choix voilà c'est tout plat civilisation
avec résumer en un seul bon soir en
serre directeur adjoint de lexpress fr
directeur délégué de l'express vous
habite éditorialistes spécialité
politique étrangère et le fait religieux
bonsoir christian et bonsoir guillaume
bernard historien des idées et
politologue habitués plutôt du vendredi
sur point de vue mais là on est
tellement contents de vous avoir qu'on
vous a demandé d'être là dès jeudi
vous êtes donc maître de conférences on
le rappelle mais ce besoin de le
rappeler à l'institut catholique
d'enseignement supérieur à la roche sur
yon alors avoue guillaume avoue
christian avoue sylvie avoue barbara et
à vous qui nous regarde et je propose ce
soir de revenir sur deux thèmes
d'abord les suite de l'audition du
professeur didier raoult l'edt hier à
l'assemblée et la passe d'armes ce matin
dans les studios de rmc et bfm tv avec
jean jacques bourdin et et on se posera
une question sur l'éventuelle
mégalomanie de didier raoul tu es una
fou qui vous a peut être échappé un prix
pourra ça traoré qui va être lauréate du
bit internacional global awards remis
par la chaîne américaine black
entertainment television l'espace de une
sorte de mtv mais plus plus axé sur la
culture afro américaine et cette chaîne
donc va décerner son prix ça traoré pour
son action en faveur de ce que la chaîne
nomme la communauté noire mondiale sur
ces sujets barbara sylvie christian
guillaume et vous qui nous regardent et
j'attends bien entendu vos commentaires
vos réactions vos avis vos points de vue
alors sur les forums du figaro vous êtes
partagés une légère majorité fait
confiance à didier raoul dans tous les
cas quand on a posé cette question sur
le site du figaro il ya 48 heures et
vous avez été nombreux à suivre son
audition à l'assemblée et regarder les
moments forts plus de 300000 vue
notamment sur notre chaîne youtube sur
l'extrait que nous avons mises en ligne
ce matin le chercheur marseillais était
également l'invité de jean-jacques
bourdin et le duo de fauves a vraiment
tourné au vinaigre
c'est ce que je n'ai fait que soigner
les gens j'ai fait soigner les gens mais
si vous faites pas de diagnostic des
gens vous pouvez pas les souches et ne
vous d'accord fut celle mais on pas
quand on dans ton qualité donc ce que je
vous ai dit est ce que je vous répète et
non des ducs donne en fait pas de
déduction fort heureuse je vous ai dit
quand on dit aux gens sur x ne vous ne
faites pas diagnostic rester à la maison
et que le message du salut des gens on
ne tue pas des gens écouter via le
répète je vais me lever mon allez donc
vous écoutez ce que je vous dis d'accord
est une erreur nous non je refuse donc
on s'en fout on peut partir tous les
deux jouent en football alors allez-y
pourrait bien compris alors je me
nourris allez-y allez-y de nombreux
professeurs de médecine à les y aller
pas partez ne portait pas j'ai des
questions vous posez nous est posée mois
les réunions internes et arrêter de me
répéter chose alors est-ce que vous avez
tué des gens et je sais pas ce n'est pas
un deal me dit ne me dites pas que je ne
pose pas de questions intelligentes
c'était la dernière phrase donc de jean
jacques bourdin sur twitter on vous pose
cette question et didier raoul est il
trop mégalo
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est vos
réponses parce que quand j'ai préparé
cette émission que écrire est sur mon
papier que je vous posais la question
vous étiez une légère majorité répondre
oui à 51%
et puis tout à l'heure juste avant le
début de cette émission vous étiez une
majorité à répondre non à 51% donc sa
bouche vous continuez à voter le débat
est en cours
ce qui est intéressant c'est vos
commentaires qui répondent en majorité
eux
non didier raoul tu n'es pas mégalo
comme clinton mubi qui lui dit non parce
que pour moi un intellectuel doit
marteler son point de vue si les
résultants de longues études du sujet ce
qui est le cas et puis parce que des
personnes aussi importante dans la
science n'ont pas à être froissés de la
sorte quand elles font que leur travail
un autre internaute lui dit non il
connaît sa valeur dans son domaine c'est
une sommité il faut le dire quand même
et puis spetsnaz nous dit non car il est
un scientifique
il sait de quoi il parle contrairement à
beaucoup son protocole a été suivie dans
plusieurs pays semble-t-il avec succès
ils apprenaient le testing la houle et à
penser gestion économie pour les tests
alors sur le site du figaro c'est un
petit peu plus partagés et il ya
notamment ce commentaire de dsc qui nous
dit légaux de raul tu es pire que le coc
vide 19 barbara lefebvre je commence
avec vous est ce que dira je suis
populaire comme l'a dit ce matin didier
raoul ta jean jacques bourdin en guise
d'argument c'est pas incohérent dans le
discours est un peu léger comme argument
ah non je ne crois pas du tout que ce
soit cohérent dans la mesure
effectivement c'est un homme extrêmement
populaire parce que à un moment donné de
cette crise sanitaire sans précédent il
a été celui qui a une parole
effectivement discordantes discordantes
vis-à-vis de son propre corps de métier
de c2c que de ses collègues médecins
mais aussi vis-à-vis évidemment la
politique sanitaire qui était mise en
place
je vous ferai remarquer quand même que
depuis deux mois
en réalité le gouvernement mène enfin la
politique sanitaire que didier raoul
prônait depuis le mois de février c'est
à dire que didier rahout ali a chu a
pesté bien que en lui aimait beaucoup de
bâtons dans les roues
et même lorsque le président la
république a cherché à déverrouiller un
certain nombre de deux d'éléments pour
faciliter le travail de didier rahout il
s'est aperçu que au sein même du
gouvernement
du côté de la direction générale de la
santé du côté du ministère de la santé
monsieur véran on ne remet tait derrière
lui les verrous donc il ya véritablement
une ya eu non peut-être pas une cabale
mais il y avait véritablement une
volonté de ne pas admettre que le
professeur out disait juste depuis le
début sur tester et isolé et faire un
confinement plus fin et non pas un
confinement de pays qui ne s'est pas
donné les moyens de se confronter à une
telle pandémie
je rappelle par ailleurs que la question
de la mégalomanie est classé dans les
psychoses délirante chronique je ne
crois pas que appel médecin avec une
telle renommée soit porteur d'une telle
pathologie psychiatrique
donc cette psychiatrisation d'un
personnage qui effectivement a une
personnalité hors norme pense à juste
titre être un sachant et il est il est
davantage que nombre d'entre nous qui
avons peuple et les plateaux télé a
parlé de sept pieds du comic sans en
savoir grand chose quand vous avez des
chaînes télé qui habite à nutritionniste
pour parler de la clé du covin ou un
orthopédiste
je ne pense pas tellement spécialiste de
la question et pour terminer je dirai si
vous voulez écouter didier rahout parler
plus calmement et aussi parler de ceux
de sujets qui l'intéressent à titre
personnel d'un point de vue
philosophique
je vous invite à les regarder sur le
site front populaire puisqu'il a rejoint
front populaire et qu' il a proposé déjà
un premier échange où il évoque ses
centres d'intérêt en particulier en
terme de philosophie
merci beaucoup barbara pour ce pour ce
premier point et puis vous rappeler la
parution du premier numéro deux fronts
populaires alors justement si votre
intervention m'amène à dire plusieurs
choses à préciser plusieurs points
moi je veux pas qu'on fasse un débat
pour ou contre raul ou pour ou contre
bourdin alors je salue quand même nicole
qui nous a rejoints dès le début de
l'émission et qui nous dit j'adore quand
quelqu'un peut rabattre le caquet de
bourda vrai qu'on dépasse justement le
le duo de fauves on en a parlé depuis
depuis ce matin et je voudrais que allez
allez un petit peu au-delà on n'est pas
scientifique vous avez raison vous
l'avez dit on n'est pas médecin donc la
question que je me pose c'est est-ce que
derrière les postures et les partis pris
on peut pas se demander si le discours
lui est cohérent et mérite d'être d'être
entendu
christian makarian ans nicole justement
nous dit il a peut-être une opinion de
lui-même mais il n'est pas mégalo il
avait une opinion une connaissance et on
lui a barré la route quand raul tu dis
il y à des conflits d'intérêt quand raul
te dis chaque année il y a des morts et
des millions de morts en raison des
infections respiratoires virales et
qu'avec le coronavirus on ne changera
pas les grandeurs sais tu sais quoi
quoiqu'ils aient quoi qu'ils disent
c'est pas s'il faut écouter
je voudrais en préalable d'abord éviter
un conflit ou un bep l'ida gérance de ma
part puisque je suis marseillais et
comme comme et qu' il ya une façon de
s'exprimer à la christian cardon il n'y
a pas vu de conflit d'intérêts pour un
cahier pas de conflit d'intérêts mais je
préfère le dire est que j'ai l'habitude
de cette façon de parler qui met en
valeur et en général la personne qui
s'exprime et il ne faut absolument pas
s'arrêter à ça je pense que ce qu'il
faut essayer de dire à ce stade du débat
c'est que sans entrer puisque je suis
totalement incompétent en matière
médicale virale épidémiologique et
consorts la seule chose que je puisse
dire en revanche c'est que dans le champ
public la façon dont le bois fera hoult
et traiter me paraît littéralement gens
pas d'autre mot délirante
c'est à dire que
le président de la république lui rend
visite dans un entretien ultra secret on
sait pas ce qu'ils se sont dit alors
raul tu dis par bribes qui lui a dit
ceci cela ma faim bref le président à
faire le déplacement quand même pour le
voir à marseille après quoi quelques
semaines après le médicament qu'il prône
et qui est rejetée par une majorité très
forte il faut quand même le rappeler du
médecin donc l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
tout simplement interdite c'est à dire
que même un médecin généraliste ne peut
pas le prescrire
c'est quelque part une manière aussi une
deuxième fois de se défier de la
médecine de ville et du personnage clé
dans nos vies qu'est le personnel le
médecin généraliste donc on est en mai
ça à l'index littéralement à l'index
scientifique
donc il en a fabriqué de façon tout à
fait logique
un véritable paria et toutes causes en
particulier dans ces moments
apocalyptique où on voit le monde qui
change le monde d'après le nouveau monde
autant de choses complètement fausse il
ya besoin de héros comme ya besoin de
médicaments miracles comme il ya besoin
de martyrs
eh bien il me semble que le professeur
out porte les trois dimensions ennuis en
lui-même il est à la fois le héros
l'automne du médicament miracle qui ne
l'est pas et le martyre puisque on lui
cloue le bec et en le prive de moyens
moi je trouve que c'est très révélateur
le dysfonctionnement bureaucratique de
système politique français qui est
absolument anormal si les scientifiques
sont en désaccord avec eux ils entrer et
beaucoup de français alors pâti de ces
désaccords et bien qu'ils règlent centre
mais qu'il ne cherche pas à coup et au
pilori un des personnages qui
s'expriment effectivement de façon très
truculente et un peu caricatural moi je
regrette mais je pense que tout ce bruit
fait autour du professeur raoul tu est
une perte de temps
je retiens qu'une seule chose et je
termine un maçon c'est que raout disait
et là je rejoins barre à le faire pas
seulement hydroxy chloroquine hydroxy
clan qui disait dépistage dépistage
dépistage et sa l'état central a dit non
au début et ça restera une faute il
disait également hydroxy hydroxy
chloroquine et azithromycine pour être
complet un coup d'oeil au forum du
figaro alors il ya des innovations vous
le voyez à ce soir
également dans la réalisation et on met
également certaines de vos citations sur
des forums du figaro mais vous commencez
vous continuez à commenter juste à
droite de ce player dans le chat je
salue notamment tic série dia nathan et
même un internaute qui se fait appeler
figaro mais en deux mots ne devons pas
avoir la même définition du mot martyrs
vous dites il d'ailleurs christian
makarian godfrey il nous disait un petit
peu plus tôt les raccourcis énoncé par
bourdin ne soigne et de passionnés égale
tués et avoir des conflits d'intérêts
c'est être vendus visait à faire dire
des horreurs à raul tu pour faire le
buzz
c'est indigne de la part d'un
journaliste moi je voudrais pas faire de
la duc on fraternise mme
à la petite semaine comment je suis on
leur reproche souvent aux médias mais je
sais pas si c'est votre avis sylvie
bommel mais moi j'ai trouvé que dans
cette dans cet échange même musclé
bordas a fait son fait son travail il
demanda il demande à raul est d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la logique en tous les
cas il essaye de voir s'il va au bout de
cette logique de ce qu'il perçoit de
cette logique c'est pas votre avis
absolument absolument dé bor bourdin a
été a fait du gourdin et a pas eu de
martyrs spéciale pour pour raul et à
traiter sont invités comme menez traite
tous on peut le regretter on peut aimer
ou pas mauvaise et c'est un style ya pas
de traitement particulier
ce que je trouve et id la pousser dans
ses retranchements parce que quand même
c'est vraiment l'a pas dit mais hier
devant la commission il a quand même dit
qu'il n'avait pas dit des choses qu'il
avait dit donc ça c'est des faits parce
que dans ce domaine là on dit beaucoup
de choses me ryan des faits qui s'oppose
pas qui s'imposent
moi ce qui m'a trouvé est ce que j'ai
trouvé fascinant c'est cette manière
qu'ils avaient de ne pas vouloir
dialoguer en sont bien la question que
vous posez c'est est ce qu'il est
mégalomane mégalomane blessure barbara
raison et paille dans son instigatrice
du terme en fait c'est comme quand on
dit dans la vie courante il est parano
sera pas mégalomane dans le langage
courant c'est un désir de gloire et
puissance exacerbée il l'a toujours eue
raoult mais je visais un très bel
article du new york times qui a
rencontré le proviseur raoult a lancé
des américains les américains qui entre
parenthèses sont aussi interdits qu'il
la chloroquine donc n'ya pas il n'y a
pas que la france un peu paga gérer non
plus donc i10 et axel kahn quitte à
scientifiques et qu'ils modeste drama
rao
il disait ceci je cite une de ses
caractéristiques c'est qu'il sait qu'il
est très bon mais une autre
caractéristique c'est que pour lui tous
les autres sont sans valeur depuis
toujours ce n'est pas nouveau et je
crois que ça ça explique quand même
beaucoup de cas en train de se passer
ben moi j'aime beaucoup les approches
psychologiques alors bon c'est voilà
c'est ma façon de faire mais c'est un
fils de médecin militaire c'est un petit
fils on sait de paul legendre est un
très grand infectiologues et qui
paradoxe amour détail amusant de
l'histoire
a été père de l'enseignement de la
déontologie et des bonnes relations
entre les médecins ce qu'il appelait
bonnes relations entre les médecins
bonvalot petit fils m'a pas tous
tellement du compte
bref je crois qu'il a 68 ans à ou il à
ceux désirant lui qui est pour tout à
fait respectable si emma s'il est un peu
disproportionné et là tout d'un coup ils
croient au début de l'infection bien
trump le sait la star mondiale c'est un
mondial on pourrait revenir tout à
l'heure quand même sur ce point et je
crois que la déception est à la hauteur
de sa la déception parce que quand même
voix la communauté scientifique qu'elle
n'est pas si divisé que ça dans le monde
maintenant on est à peu près rien non
plus tout le monde est d'accord pour des
rats et donc il a une déception terrible
par rapport à ce cas ce qu'il a imaginé
être au début de corinthians qui l'amène
à des positions quand même très forte et
chez bourdin jamais pris sur une
compression ce que vous disiez sur la
personnalité maintenant justement ballon
au fond en gros on vous dit
caricaturé à grands traits mais
caricaturer pardon et par des agrès
dans l'île et il est désagréable mais au
fond dans ce qu'il dit dans le fond du
discours est ce que c'est ça mérite de
ne pas être écoutés et surtout est-ce
que c'est s'il faut bon ça a toujours
été un rebelle à il a écrit un bouquin
dix ans toutes les erreurs qu'on a
toutes les histoires qu'on vous raconte
qu'ils sont fausses bon il a pas fait
que ça les fait des trucs très bien
c'est quand même c'est moi juste quand
même sa mégalomanie c'est un garçon qui
a signé il est quand même l'auteur de sa
propre notoriété ici là aussi je me
réfère au new york times y signe il a
signé plusieurs milliers milliers de
publications dans le monde
là où ses confrères en plus dans leur
vie en trombe dans son antenne et en
particulier ici dit toutes celles qui
sortent de liège tout c'est très rare ça
n'arrive jamais que c'est bon j'ai juste
vous poser cette question au contraire
qui mériterait d'être écouté une façon
de couvrir ses équipes
moi je trouve au contraire donc on
aimerait parfois avoir le le grand chef
qui soutient ces noms moi quand j'ai eu
un patron ça m'est arrivé quelques
mauvais qu'il connaît pas scientifique
est travaillée par la recherche
scientifique qui signé des articles
auxquels est pas mis à mal le
journalisme et la recherche scientifique
se fait nulle part dans le monde
passons est ce que c'est ce qu'il n'a
pas raison sur certaines choses sûrement
le testing il avait raison vous avez
raison mais il n'ya pas que lui qui l'a
fait il est très fort et on a testé à
amiens nat et à lille dans la discrétion
le truc c'est que je pense que même si
la raison une autre question c'est
est-ce qu'ils servent sa cause en se
conduisant comme ça finalement pas du
tout à supposer même que la chloroquine
ait eu un effet est ce que est ce que ce
comportement de havrais semblables et
ses confrères enfin et puis là il est
suivi par peron c'est quand même est-ce
que ça a exposé moi je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas en tout cas
l'interview du professeur peron des
interviews du processeur peron
d'ailleurs auquel vous faites allusion
sont à retrouver sur le site du figaro
interview papier par charles jaigu et
interviews à vidéo j'ai fait lundi
dernier pub donc pub gratuite
guillaume bernard il ya quelque chose
qui me frappe dans l'extrait que
convient d'entendre et qu'on commente là
et il ya en fin d'audition
c'est un petit peu ce que disait sylvie
bommel à l'instant c'est qu'on a
l'impression que disons qu'il supporte
pas le dialogue en tout cas il supporte
pas la
critique et quand bourdin lui dit ce
n'est pas la popularité qui soignera
hoult s'emporte s'offusque et vigilance
d'abord vous allez écouter ce que je
vous dis c'est quand même le recours au
vieil argument d'autorité écouté le
débat que nous avons là ce soir ne
m'inquiétais c'est à dire que je
craignais qu'il ne sût pas intéressant
alors qu'en fait je le trouve vraiment
passionnant parce que justement
l'attitude je trouve de jean jacques
bourdin qui est effectivement assez
habituel là est tombé sur un os
jusqu'à présent bourdin interviews des
politiques qui ont lu avant d'arriver à
l'émission des fiches de synthèse que
leurs collaborateurs l'auront fait est
là il est tombé sur quelqu'un qui a
vraiment travaillé sur la question
qu'ils aient tort ou qu'ils aient raison
en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui est
spécialiste des questions dont il parle
et qui naturellement ne peut pas
vraiment se laisser déstabiliser
bourdin est tombé sur un os les tomber
sur quelqu'un qui est prêt à lui
résister et qui est prêt à ne pas
accepter de se laisser déstabiliser
à l'évidence bourdin a quand même été
quelque peu agressif il a cherché à
présenter les positions de didier rahout
comme étant des positions très
manichéenne sans subtilité en les
simplifiant à outrance et et l'autre a
réagi moi j'avoue que c'est des moments
de télévision qui me ravit ce parce que
je trouve que ça nous change un petit
peu du du ronron quotidien et
sincèrement c'est vrai que j'aurais
plutôt tendance à pencher du côté de
raul ne serait ce que parce qu'il a été
un de ceux qui depuis cette affaire de
deux crises sanitaires et de grand
renfermement lorsque c'est quand même ce
que nous avons subi pendant plus de deux
mois l'ensemble de leur population sous
news du livret a à a
ce confinement il a été un de ceux qui
s'y opposent et n'était pas ma question
la question c'est peut-être la question
qui est posée par ba binoclard pose
différemment
babineau que je salue
on va perdre notre fidèle du figaro qui
après n'apprécie pas apparemment le
professeur à ault puisqu'il lui dit il
est très isolé dans le monde de la
médecine et son traitement a été un
échec car massivement rejeté ça peut
être on peut en débattre c'est une autre
question
par contre babineau nous vous nous dites
également didier raoul tu dois apporter
les preuves de ses accusations
or il ne le fait pas et ça c'était vrai
autant dans l'audition hier quand il a
mis quand il a évoqué les conflits
d'intérêts et notamment avec la firme
gilead
il évoque mais il ne démontre pas il dit
je suis un grand scientifique et j'ai
toujours été un grand scientifique mais
sans essayer chercher à le démontrer il
ya quelque chose quand même qui est un
peu quand même qui est un peu saisissant
nom alors je crois que là vous évoquez
vincent deux choses distinctes
il ya la question de savoir est ce qu'il
ya l'efficacité réelle de la démarche
qui est la sienne qui est de dire et des
pistes ceux qui sont malades et on ne
traite que ceux qui sont malades et le
plus tôt possible parce que si ça arrive
trop tard c'est devenu inutile et
deuxièmement évidemment on met
uniquement à l'écart je dirais de la vie
sociale ceux qui sont malades
bon ça c'est la première question c'est
la question scientifique sincèrement je
vous signale quand même qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui ont pratiqué cette
méthode là et est me semble-t-il qui ont
eux réussi à aa à comment dire à juguler
à juguler la crise sanitaire et puis il
ya le deuxième élément que vous évoquez
c'est l'aspect politique c'est la
possibilité qu'il puisse y avoir de la
corruption c'est la possibilité que je
sais qu'ils ne démontrent pas il évoque
qu'il a fait mais ne démontre pas ils ne
démontrent pas mais comme il l'a dit
comme il l'a dit devant les
parlementaires il l'a dit c'est vous
êtes une commission denquête c'est aussi
à vous d'enquêté et vous lancer ces
conflits d'intérêts d'ailleurs ces
conflits d'intérêts sont apparents
puisqu'ils sont sur la plateforme de la
transparence
la transparence de la santé has et sur
le et il ya aussi un site européen
et d'ailleurs on le voit qu'un certain
nombre de chercheurs sont liées à pas
seulement à gilead et donc aurait mené
ces villes mais aussi à d'autres
laboratoires et qu'on nous dise que
monsieur yazdan yazdanpanah qui est
membre du conseil scientifique n'est
plus couvert par le conflit d'intérêts
parce que ça fait trois ans qu'il n'a
pas touché d'argent de gilead ou qui
enfin ça ça reste encore
et justement c'est un des éléments la
commission denquête naka investiguer
donc c'est simplement ce qu'a dit
professeur raoul la réalité des conflits
d'intérêts ça a été démontré par de
nombreuses enquêtes y compris des
enquêtes de journalistes qui ont montré
à quel point aujourd'hui les
laboratoires ont complètement infiltrés
tout le monde de la médecine et de la
recherche est d'ailleurs le land set lui
même le le directeur du land 7 il ya
quelques années regretté qu'un certain
nombre d'études publiées dans le land
cette fois en réalité bidonné pour faire
la promotion de deux médicaments en
faveur de sa part a beau merci
d'attendre nous dit les statistiques ne
mentent pas le lin de 7,6 alors nathan
j'ai envie de vous citer mark twain qui
disait dans la vie à trois catégories de
mensonges les mensonges les gros
mensonges et les statistiques
expat liberté nous dit bourdin a montré
sa tendance à faire des raccourcis
trompeurs je vous trouve sévère
je voulais 10 et
nous on était des raccourcis linda nous
dit ah oui mais il était clair son
action on vous posait la question sur
twitter donc justement didier rahout
est-il le professeur didier raoult est
il trop mégalo et vous répondez non à
51% on vous pose une autre question sur
twitter à